باصابه طفيفه وجروح قابله للتضميض وان
حفرت بعقولهم نالوا الفرصه الثانيه اطفال
اخرجوا من تحت الانقاض ليفترشوا اسره احد
مشافي حار في ادلب هؤلاء يرون بمن يعاملهم
من ممرضات حضن ام فقدوها او اخفي عنهم
مصيرها في عندي مريضه اسمها جنان جنان
جنيد هي من اطفال اللي طلعت من تحت
الانقاض هاي جنان عندي اياها يعني
ما عندي اولاد فحس
فبحسوا الدفاع الاول في الكارثه هذه المره
تشاركته مجموعتان ففي وقت كان عناصر الخوض
البيضاء منتشرين بين الانقاض يتتبعون
اطراف خيطان علهم يجدون صوتا هنا او يدا
هناك تلتمس من ياخذ بها كان الاطباء وطاقم
التمريض على قله عناصره يهرعون من زاويه
الى اخرى لمحاوله من ياتيهم بعضهم لفظ
انفاسه الاخيره على مداخل المشافي واخرون
على ايديهم على وقت
يجيبوا لي الطفل فانا عم باخذه فعم
بيقولوا لي عايش عايش فبدي
بكون انفاسه الاخيره يعني ما بعرف لانه
انا فقدت رفيقتي هون
راحت الضحايا الزلزال كانت ممرضه معنا
جابوا لنا رئيس المشفى فنحني عرفناه
استشهد الله يرحمه فتركناه والتفتنا لغيره
الله يرحمه ففي عالم لسه لسا عايشه لسه
بدها ايانا فنحن رحنا لهنيك الحزن المؤجل
رافق صرخه الخذلان فالاخيره باتت مالوفه
في سوريا وسقلتها حرب ممتده منذ 12 عاما
لتكمل عليها كارثه راح ضحيتها الالاف في
كل زاويه منها هناك من يبكي الفقد ويقول
لو كان هناك امكانيات او مساعدات لربما من
ابكيه ظل موجودا الارض خزنتنا
الحرب خزنتنا
كل الدنيا خذلتنا ما حدا اجا انقاذ كان
الدفاع المدني بالخط الاول
ما حدا اجانا من برا فخلاص وقفت وقف الصوت
الاصوات اللي نزلنا نسمعه تحت الانقاذ
ساعتين ثلاثه كان ما كان ضل اصوات